i once saw a box a vote box
being emptied onto the table at a count
in a place called oldham in the north of
england and
unbelievably of the of the thousand to
say ballots
that were in that box the percentage
that were voting for labor
was 100
that is literally impossible so you know
that that is what keeping sadiq khan
holding on in london is the power of
that postal vote
you know it's kind of funny because i
remember when when i met you for
breakfast one morning and we took a
picture and i posted the picture
and then people were saying oh look
you're with that racist that racist and
meanwhile
we sat there for two hours we talked
about freedom we talked about liberty
all this stuff
and it's very similar to going to a
trump rally when i started going to
those rallies
and i'm thinking oh am i going to see
these racists here or something like
that
and it's the happiest most joyful people
who in many cases are not political at
all they're just there because
they want to express some level of
freedom something like that
yeah no absolutely i mean this has been
a constant attempt for the left to
tarnish us with this racism word
and it just doesn't work anymore the
real racists
are actually those behind black lives
matter and i really mean that i really
mean that
you know when martin luther king said in
that amazing speech what i mean what an
orator
the guy was but when he said i want my
four children
to be judged not for the color of their
skin
but by the content of their character
and now what's happening
through blm and elsewhere is we are
dividing people up
into different groups dividing them up
on the grounds of race
ethnicity gender whatever else it may be
and that is
disastrous that is destructive that is
the real racism
and i loathe it and i want to live in a
country
where everybody is treated exactly
the same because if you start giving
special
privileges to certain groups you then
automatically alienate
other groups who feel left out a free
fair society would have a quality of
opportunity
for all and of course i condemn and
loathe
racism and yes there are some there is a
fringe
on the extreme right who i think we
should simply they would have nothing
to do with whatsoever but you're quite
right
you know whether it was my ukip
supporters my brexit party supporters
trump supporters at the rallies these
are very very good
decent people and the more mainstream
media
you know or hillary clinton point
fingers at them and call them
deplorable or ignorant or stupid the
greater their resolve
to fight back what do you make about how
the the blm
movement some of the antifa stuff that
now that is being exported i mean you
guys are seeing some of that on the
streets of london now and it's happening
in other western countries as well
you know i mean within 24 hours of the
death of george floyd within 24 hours
there were riots in the streets of
london so don't tell me
this was a spontaneous outpouring this
was all planned
they've been waiting for the opportunity
and i was disgusted
i mean to see the cenotaph in london the
monument
to one and a half million dead fighting
fighting for liberty in two world wars
to see that desecrated
to see the churchill statue repeatedly
desecrated
and what stunned me was to see british
police officers taking the knee
in the streets and your police police
officers don't even have guns
uh they don't well some do some do some
do but i think we're gonna have to
that's a policy that we'll need to
change no question about that but
but to take the knee to and i was going
on uk tv and radio and writing
say to everybody understand what this is
if this organization was
genuinely about equality genuinely
about getting rid of racial prejudice
i'd have no problem with it
whatsoever but the truth of it is and
you've only got to read their website
you know they they tell you they're in a
vowedly marxist organization
intent on defunding the police bringing
down western capitalism
and for a new marxist order to take its
place
that is what they're doing they are
trying to destroy us and yet
i've been horrified on both sides of the
pond to see
big corporations you know trying to say
wonderful things about them i even saw
saint john's church opposite the white
house
i was there yesterday and they've got a
black lives matter poster
but what is going on don't people
realize this is a
bad dangerous organization so i i you
know
these are things that really grieve me
and it's the lack of courage
of enough people to stand up and tell
the truth for fear
of being called racist so with that all
in mind what do you think is going to
happen with this mayoral race
in in london because it looks it looks a
little messy
at the moment well one of the things
that
has has changed politics um in the
united kingdom
has been postal voting early mail out
voting we've seen it abused
again and again and again there is no
country
in which this is safe and i was i was
trying to warn america
this time last year that if you went
down this route you know the left will
always win at this
because you see if you think you're
morally superior
cheating is quite an easy thing to do
whereas our side
just asks i won't she and i'm pleased to
say
that really but but you're never going
to win the one country
that's got this right is france now the
french
the french don't get much right in my
opinion but
but the one thing they've got right
they've seen how open
postal voting is to fraud intimidation
and abuse
and they've banned it completely so do
you know what they do in france
if you want to vote in france i'll tell
you what happens you go along to the
local hall
you show your identification you're
given a piece of paper
you go into a polling booth in secrecy
you put a cross next to the candidate or
party you prefer
and after that there are no voting
machines used
there's no need for those they're
manually counted they're put in piles
and totaled up and that is free and open
democracy there's a big lesson we can
learn from it now what khan has got
going for him
in london is they've signed up vast
numbers
of the muslim population to these postal
votes
and i look i know that in those
communities
you know the women are signed up for
postal votes but do you actually think
they ever
ever ever get the chance to exercise
that
of course they don't i i once saw
i once saw a box a vote box
being emptied onto the table at a count
in a place called oldham in the north of
england and
unbelievably of the of the thousand to
say ballots
that were in that box the percentage
that were voting for labour
was 100
that is literally impossible so you know
that that is what keeping sadiq khan
holding on in london is the power of
that postal vote
uh but even in london which has been the
great
labor stronghold even there the party is
now on
it is seriously what do you think of my
friend lawrence fox you think he has a
chance to actually
from a liberal a true liberal
perspective do you think he has a chance
to to fight off the progressive
movement onslaught look look i
i admire lawrence i like lawrence i mean
you know
he's a great guy and the next time
you're in london we'll go out together
you know he's
he is a great guy to be with um
starting new political movements from
scratch
you know a little something about it i
mean i mean it's done
you know it took me so many years
to get ukip said i mean in the end we
had 400 chapters around the country
millions of supporters but it doesn't
happen overnight
now the things that lawrence is battling
for are fundamentally important issues
you know it is it is about the
relationship
between the individual and the state and
this is something that we've always
prided ourselves on
you know frankly ever since magna carta
but but going all through the years
we've been the freest of all european
countries in fact the freest of all the
english-speaking world
we've never had to have id cards or any
of these things
now with covid we've seen those
liberties stripped away
in the most remarkable and very hasty
fashion so look
lawrence in terms of making the
arguments he's in the right place
i wish him well but if i'm being honest
with you it's going to take a lot of
years
to build a movement that's big enough to
be do you make a distinction at this
point between
someone that would say they're an old
school liberal and a conservative does
that even is there is there any
distinction worth mentioning at this
point
well i mean the funny thing isn't it you
know i mean if if if you'd said to me
20 years ago nigel where are you on the
left-right spectrum
i'd have called myself a gladstone
liberal you know gladstone was a liberal
prime minister
back in the back in the 19th century but
one who believed in freedom of the
individual
uh you know believed in the country um a
jfk democrat
from our perspective basically yeah yeah
i have to say
i've stopped using that word you know
classical liberalism you know if you go
to the oxford union
uh you know and debate with some of the
brightest students in the world
maybe there you can talk about classical
liberalism if you try and talk about
classical liberalism to anybody else
they sort of you know if they're
conservatives just go back because they
because
because the word liberal now now means
illiberal
the liberals want to ban everything the
liberals want to control everything
the liberals don't even believe in free
speech so yeah
classical liberalism i'm afraid is only
for the debating chamber
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification
bell